Friedman was a great teacher and I think
that's what many at the unity of his
former students at the University of
Chicago would say is that as much as he
was a great public intellectual a great
scholar he was also a great teacher hi
I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Lani eben Stein
he's the editor most recently of the
indispensable Milton Friedman essays on
politics and economics thank you doctor
even Stein tell us what is what did you
find indispensable about Milton Friedman
and I mean this is actually a pretty
thin book for a guy who wrote thousands
of pages what how did you decide what
made the cut these were essays that I
felt were neglected over the years and
that together both more popular essays
and then also essays more specifically
in economics that it would give a an
acquaintance with Friedman that would be
Adventist awk about a couple of them
what was it that turned Friedman on to
liberalism classical liberal libertarian
is a good question i asked him that and
i think it was John Stuart Mill as much
as anything else he considered mill to
be on liberty to be his introduction to
libertarian thought I think that he was
really led through his analysis of
economics positive economics as he
termed it technical economics to embrace
a classical liberal position of limited
government and less government talk a
little bit about the quality of his work
as a public intellectual I mean he was
very generous to his collaborators he
was very generous to the people he
disagreed with he has tons of good
things to say about John Maynard Keynes
I mean we're just coming at the outbreak
so yeah well I think that Friedman
thought that the best way to persuade
people was attempt to reason on the
facts a society that aims for equality
before Liberty will end up with neither
equality nor Liberty
you can only aim at equality by giving
some people the right to take things
from others and what ultimately happens
when you aim at equality is that a and B
decide what C shall do for d
except that they take a little bit of a
commission off on the way this was this
whole distinction between positive and
normative economics that there's a
difference between the way the economy
works and the way that we'd like to have
the outcomes in the economy be so we
should at least try to come to agreement
on the way the economy works so if
that's the approach you take and I think
that will lead you to try to ascribe to
your adversaries the best of intentions
the most wisdom the most intelligence if
you want them to be willing to persuade
you then you have to be willing to be
persuaded by them would he be happy with
monetary policy in the United States
that's a really good question I believe
that Friedman would have said that in
the case of the Great Recession as in
the case of the Great Depression that in
an extraordinary circumstance
extraordinary policy can be required and
he would have favored a more stimulative
policy by the Fed so to have the Fed
pump even more money into the economy
well whether he would be in favor of the
Fed pumping more money into the economy
at this point in time or whether he
would say the feds already gone far
enough is another question I would think
that on standard monetary analysis we
are going to inflate a face inflation at
some point in time but according to
standard theory it also should have
arrived by this point right so well does
that point to the idea that maybe
Friedman's insights are no longer you
know really applicable now well I think
that the idea is remain applicable and
it's the circumstances which are
different and the question is is what is
the effect of monetary policy and fiscal
policy in our current times what would
Friedman say I should he say the baby
boomer shouldn't retire or what you know
how would he deal with this coming
deluge of retiring well two or three
things I think that he would favor
increases in retirement ages I think he
would favor decreases in Social Security
benefits I think he would particularly
say that Social Security benefits that
are being received yeah I think he would
favor means testing of Social Security I
I think that he would favor
privatization of Social Security so in
all those areas those are long run salut
shins we've got a lot of people who are
retiring right now so that's a talk a
little bit about you know how did you
how did you first encounter Milton
Friedman in words and in life I first
interviewed him for my biography of
Friedrich Hayek and he was in California
as I was and I wrote him a letter and I
said could I come up and interview you
he got right back to me happy to do so
come on up and that was nineteen
ninety-five or 1996 and I remember very
well the first time I interviewed him
the first thing I asked him I said now
do you mind if I tape our conversation
and he said I have a single rule what I
say to one person I say to everyone I
never say anything off the record
Friedman was a great teacher and I think
that's what many at the unit many of his
former students at the University of
Chicago would say is that as much as he
was a great public intellectual a great
scholar he was also great teachers well
and that's one of the reason one of the
many reasons he's indispensable even
years after he has passed on Lanny eben
Stein editor of the indispensable Milton
Friedman thanks for talking to reason TV
great thank you for reason TV I'm nickel
aspect thank you
you